when it opened in 1981 the Humber Bridge
was the longest single span suspension
bridge in the world more than 1400
meters of road weighing 17,000 tons held
up by cables that weigh thousands of
tons themselves those cables are made up
of more than 14,000 individual wires or
anchored into concrete foundations on
the shore and those cables and the whole
structure in turn is held up by these
enormous towers the bridge is so wide
and so tall that while both towers are
vertical they're just a couple of
centimeters further apart at the top
because of the curvature of the earth
nearly 40 years after it opened this
bridge is about a third of the way
through its design lifespan and it's
time for a checkup
back in 90s in the United States
Bridge engineers started to unearth
severe cable corrosion in their early
structures so they weren't they were
built in suspension bridges in the 30s
the way that the cables were designed to
be kept watertight was once the wires
had been spun and formed a cable and
compacted the open wires were coated
with lead paste which is led and linseed
oil wrapping wire was then added around
the outside of the cable
trapping the lead paste and effectively
keeping the cable watertight and it was
thought that would be sufficient
inspections in the United States
demonstrated that moisture was still
penetrating and gathering in the main
cables and causing significant corrosion
because inside here it was its own mini
climate in effect so it was affected by
external temperatures day night winter
summer this is a brutal environment for
the cables we're near the ocean for a
start and down by the road
there's engine exhaust and spray
remember the cables aren't one solid
piece of metal they're made up of
thousands of individual wires and while
they're packed tightly their cylinders
so there will always be a slight air gap
between them and that air gap is sort
water bursts corrosion of steel or iron
cannot occur below 40 percent relative
humidity there's approximately 15 to 20
percent open space in this compacted
kernel if you complete that volume below
40 percent then effectively corrosion is
halted inside the main deck of the
bridge there are plant rooms that
produce dehumidified air that air is
then pumped up to the main cable and
injected into a stainless steel sleeve
that surrounds the main cable the
relative humidity of the air blown into
the cable is low enough to have an
affinity to collect moisture as it
travels through the cable dry in the
cable and exhausting the moisture to
atmosphere and that is a continuous
24-hour cycle 365 days a year
essentially for the rest of the bridges
life so Humber Bridge board first
inspected their main cables in 2009 and
then deployed Deva defecation the
following year 2010 here we are ten
years later in 2019 re inspecting the
cable to ascertain the effectiveness of
that dehumidification system what we do
is with a sledgehammer we drive the
wedges in to form an open wedge in the
cable from each wedge line the
consultant engineer will select a wife
and then our guys will come along and
sample that particular wire and remove
approximately a 5 meter length to then
take the data that they need to collect
from the cable we then select a 5 meter
length from the drum of the new wire and
splice that in with Ferrell's and remove
the wedges and that wedge light is
unfinished
that is unrepeated 7 more times around
the circumference of the cable and then
that effectively is the inspection
complete with 100 ton hydraulic jacks at
each corner I compress the cable back to
its original diameter the idea that the
wires are slightly corroded could be
but it's well well within design
tolerances and it's been noticed early
and dealt with and they're keeping a
watch on them just in case
but bridges elsewhere in the world that
aren't inspected where infrastructure
isn't maintained where cutbacks mean
that this isn't happening those should
give you just a little cause for concern
the Homburg bridge is doing just fine
that works all right we're gonna go for
the drone shot
you